john lester's set to go to work three
and three last year for the cubs with a
5.16 cra in 12 starts
and he is ready to throw his first pitch
as a national to miguel rojas the
shortstop swinging a high fly ball left
center field and deep schwarber and
robles back at schwarber on the warning
track and he makes the catch so john
lester is off and running in the 2021
season the numbers on pablo lopez again
start number six at least six innings in
three of the five starts coming off a
really good outing one run in six
innings against the giants marlon scored
four in the ninth so
another no decision for pablo but uh of
course that doesn't shortchange what
he's been able to do two singles and a
walk have loaded the bases for the
nationals here in the first inning and a
chance now for kyle schwarber one-two
pitch he comes up with the fastball and
is popped in the air foul behind third
base john bertie is there to make the
catch and pablo's out of the inning it
might not have been as far up as he
wanted to get it but it got the job done
runners first and second two out no
score top of the second and lester
[ __ ] set swinging a slow ground ball pass
leicester right side harrison fields
easy play to bell it's time to get pablo
lopez
and the side is retired
so the marlins have first and third
with two down here in the third swinging
a ground ball left side diving stop
castro pops up throws to second gets the
out to retire the side
starlin castro saves a run
robbing his former teammate brenson with
a diving play to the glove side a
sparkling defensive play for castro and
lester's out of trouble in the third
inning
five to four on the force play and the
inning is over
john lester
threw four scoreless innings thus far
and so that puts runners on first and
second so garrett cooper who's singled
in the first inning will come up now in
a scoreless game ground ball hard right
at turner nicely done to second across
the first to turn the six four three a
huge double play
behind john lester and the southpaw has
five scoreless innings under his belt
one out robles at first in the scoreless
game last in the fifth again you realize
he's talented throw down to second and
it's in time
and now miggy comes up playing with
second base
the throw from leon looked like it
took rojas right into the
the slide of robles which was a good
thing in terms of the tag
but it may have created some unwanted
contact between
mickey and
and rolex well i think this was a delay
steal by roblox let's take another look
sure is this is classic delay steal
couple of shuffle steps and go but look
at sandy leone all over it he was
watching the entire time and well
that's how he's out at second base miggy
miggy rose sacrificed the left foot to
keep him off the back clinging takes
over for lesser to face duval brinson
and birdie here in the top of the sixth
inning called strike three
duvall started to toss the back of the
dugout he stopped balling up in here and
nearly hit the opening up fire in the
head because he kind of aborted mid
backflip
and so now he's laughing and apologizing
to roberto ortiz
the backflip didn't help him when he
almost fell apart in the head
it might have been straight he got stuck
to his to his hands
[Applause]
pablo lopez still rolling along pitches
into the bottom of the sixth
and paul right now that's the the
biggest story tonight really is that
pablo has gone in against the team
that's had his number in a stadium that
he has struggled in before and has done
everything that we've seen him do this
year which is compete good look at that
changing up
just his second strikeout tonight but
it's out number one in the sixth yeah
but there's been lots of bad contact and
i've been a couple of hits but uh that
changeup may be the best one of the
night to turner the guy that you want
out of the way the fastest and the
nationals have first and third here in
the bottom of the sixth inning first
ball hitting ground ball to short to
second one back to first double play
inning over how about that pablo lopez
induces a double play so rainey is going
to face the opposing pitcher pablo lopez
who's only thrown 67 pitches it's a
chopping ground ball left side turner
moves to his right to backhand the high
bounce the throw is high and pulls bell
off the bag and he misses the sweep tag
did he touch the bag no he missed the
base so josh bill did the right thing by
stepping on the base right after he ran
by so this should be an out
he didn't come anywhere close to it he
dragged that left foot
he is out replay worked in that case the
call over turn the put out will be six
to three and
take the error off the board and that is
out number one schwarber's on with a one
out single in the seventh one oh pitch
broken background ball to first aguilar
goes down to second they get one biggie
back to first they get two
for the third time in the game for the
second inning in a row
an inning ending twin killing this one
goes three six three anthony bass the
first marlins reliever out of their pen
tonight after seven very good innings
from pablo lopez so the gnats have speed
at first base to begin the bottom of the
eighth an infield single the 1-1 to
stevenson ground ball right side looks
like a double play ball diaz rojas
aguilar 4-6-3 it's the fourth time
tonight the marlins have turned two
bases empty two down it was a slider on
the outside spot right to east on diaz
flips over to gohas
to complete the double play
but every single inning it seems like
the nationals have gotten somebody on
base they have things cooking and the
double play has been what's been killing
nissan diaz intentionally walked bounced
to the pitcher grounded a third
goal for two
fastball right side there's harrison
he'll go to turner
[Applause]
he got that in the air didn't he
double play they're gonna go ahead and
touch
first base
and that'll do a double play
a lot of marlins on the infield
a little confused
so it's a line drive double play goes
463 anyway yeah that's true because
turner made the throw and he is the
winning run at second so here's josh
bell still capable of ending this thing
with one swing swinging a tapper to the
right side it'll be a race between bell
and floro and floro gets there first
and so
brad hand will now face garrett cooper
with runners at the corners and two outs
i know pitch the cooper is in the air
left field shallow sinking quickly and
down for a base head garrett cooper
delivers a two-run single in the top of
the 10th devers comes home to score it's
one nothing marlins oh what a beauty
right there just a broken bat ball
strong enough
cooper is strong enough to be able to
get it out there over
the head of turner who's running after
it trying to make a play
the cooper just too strong is able to
put it out there in no man's land so as
kyle schwarber comes to the plate
schwarber represents the winning run the
nationals down one nothing swinging a
long drive right center field back on
this one as harrison looking up and this
one is gone
into the second deck
it's a lead off walk-off two-run homer
for kyle schwarber
nationals win at 2-1
schwarber's hit two home runs this
season they're both walk-off shots
and he sends him home happy